das thema jeden tag die not der künstler
ausgefallene konzerte roland kaiser darf
sarah connor nicht
wie ist die lage bei den djs es ist so
dass viele von uns ohne arbeit sind
derzeit und das schon seit mitte märz
ihr seid die klubs zu haben festivals
finden ja auch keine stadt aktuell das
heißt es bleiben vielleicht noch für den
einen oder anderen die hochzeit oder der
geburtstag oder was jetzt auch immer
mehr im trend liegt die party zu hause
wie kann man sich das denn vorstellen du
bist ja wirklich mit großen stars auch
aufgetreten hat tolle remixe gemacht
kannst du dir vorstellen bei einer
hochzeit aufzulegen
naja ich bin ja die schon sehr lange und
auch aus leidenschaft deswegen ist mir
also ich spiele auch zeitnah auch nicht
so viele wie vielleicht sich der eine
oder andere hochzeitsgast wünschen würde
aber normalerweise bin ich ja eher ein
elektronischer künstler und bin auf
festivals und in clubs zu hause aber
auch gerne mal eine hochzeit das macht
auch spaß natürlich wie sieht es denn so
mit der kohle aus du hast uns im vorfeld
erzählt du musst da auch relativ viel
honorar verzichten wie kommst du hier zu
über die runden
aktuell hält mich meiner freundin die
ist in der gastro tätig und betreibt
seit fünf jahren einen restaurant im
chiemgau unten auf einem golfclub da
hält sich aus wir haben uns ein paar
aushilfen gespart und haben uns gesagt
kommen dann schmeißen wir zusammen und
auch der gastro geht's ja nicht
besonders gut da da helfen wir eben
zusammen jetzt gerade das heißt also duh
steht hinter dem tresen und zapfte oder
bedient die gäste wie kann ich mir das
vorstellen
ganz genauso sieht so aus ich bin da
oberkellner bin auch vor kurzem eher als
befördert worden vor drei wochen glaube
ich und vielleicht ein neuer berufszweig
wer weiß
ja das muss man sich wirklich mal auf
der zunge zergehen lassen wirklich der
start ist der kellner hat jetzt wie viel
geld fehlt dir da jetzt na ja man kann
sich so ungefähr vorstellen dass man im
sommer ist ja auch noch hauptsaison man
geht jetzt ich glaube aktuell bei mir
sind um die 80 shows die abgesagt worden
sind das ist schon ein sechsstelliger
betrag der jetzt durch die lappen geht
oder die man nicht als umsatz verbuchen
kann
und kann man das irgendwie nachholen was
glaubst du geht es wieder weiter
ich hoffe bald ich hoffe dass das dass
die korona pandemie bald zu ende ist
auch völlig ungeeignet dessen was man
darüber denken mag
aber natürlich kann ich auch verstehen
dass clubs und festivals die sind die am
längsten müssen denn das ist man
wirklich nah aneinander da wird an einer
sich aneinander gerieben und miteinander
getanzt
das soll ja auch so sein ja ich hoffe
dass vielleicht unser immunsystem bald
meinen weg findet oder ist bald einen
impfstoff gibt oder in ein vernünftiges
mittel dagegen und ich hoffe dass die
menschen distanzen nicht verlernt haben
und auch das feiern nicht verlernt haben
aber wenn ich mir das aktuelle geschehen
so anschaue dann wollen die menschen
feiern und tanzen wollen auch kultur
erfahren
es ist nur schade dass bei den djs oder
jetzt einmal in der
veranstaltungsbranche da halt auch mit
zweierlei maß gemessen wird also zum
beispiel die hochkultur die wird ja
immer schon bezuschusst und supported da
finden aktuell konzerte statt in der
oper in münchen sind mittlerweile 500
gäste erlaubt man mister leider mit
zweieinhalb mit zweierlei maß wie man so
schön sagt aber gut
wer weiß ich hoffe dass es bald
weitergeht
reg dich das auf das also die jets halt
ja oder auch tanzveranstaltung ja so ein
bisschen verwöhnt sind aber tatsächlich
oper findet so allmählich wieder statt
ich finde es schade weil ich finde
kultur ist kultur und wenn man da jetzt
abstriche macht und sagt opa ist cool
und tanzen ist nicht geholt dann ist das
meinungsbildend und davon habe ich noch
nie etwas gehalten ich finde das eine
tanzveranstaltung oder in den club das
ist das gehört zu unserer kultur das
gehört zum menschen die leute wollen
ausgehen die wollen feiern die wollen
die die in die alltagssorgen vergessen
die wollen
durchzechte nächte haben und genau das
ist es eben und wir sind jetzt nicht
eine horde wilder die den ganzen tag nur
feiern und dann den rest der woche
irgendwie damit verbringt den krater
auszukurieren sondern einen da steckt
tatsächlich auch business dahinter da
sind viele leute die extrem darunter
leiden dass sie nicht nur die
klubbesitzer da sind die barkeeper sind
die technik leute dass die firmen aber
egal wo man hinschaut die welche
eventbranche auch immer es trifft sie
alle hart von messebau bis zur hochzeit
branche wie gesagt die leiden alle und
das ist tatsächlich schade dass es zum
start so wenig hilfe gibt und dass das
so wenig sagen wir mal so so wenig
aufmerksamkeit für diese art von leute
gibt
da muss ich mal an kempkens dazu nehmen
die kritik ja der staat tut zu wenig
sind tatsächlich so solo selbstständige
oder einzelkämpfer künstler sind die
vergessen worden
ich würde hat manchmal so bisschen den
eindruck ja es gibt ja natürlich auch
diese möglichkeiten auf kurzzeitige
kredit ja es gab diese diese schnell
kredite diese unterdrückung
überbrückungsgeld die gezahlt wurden
aber diese natürlich schnell
aufgebraucht gewesen und die ticket
lösung bringt den künstler nix und
deswegen glaube ich hier wie tom novy
gesagt hat wenn ich mal nach 2005 zurück
schaue da war ja mit seinem mit seinem
superhit take jetzt ganz groß in den
dance charts sind meistgespielte song in
den deutschen radios und ich glaube das
ist ja auch das was wir heute irgendwie
spielen müssten take it also die
gelegenheit beim schopf packen und ich
denke mal das ist genau das richtige so
wie das ja auch hier gemacht wird
noch eine frage kommen die leute was wir
so hören haben im moment auch gar nicht
so lustig sagt natürlich die leute
wollen tanzen aber wir sind zum beispiel
von konzertveranstaltungen konzerte in
geschlossenen räumen oder hallen da
würde auch in momenten ticket vorverkauf
sehr schleppend anlaufen
wie siehst du die diskussion ist die
jetzt regelrecht verwöhnt oder in die
ecke gestellt oder bleibt da noch was
positives
ja das ist sicherlich ein großes thema
denn die leute sind natürlich
traumatisiert die leute haben angst
wer will da noch hingehen natürlich ich
weiß es nicht ich glaube wenn man müsste
den also man müsste erst mal wieder man
müsste erst mal wieder öffnen und dann
müsste man halt auch mit guten und
sicheren konzepten kommen wenn ich mir
allerdings momentan so die szene
anschauen auch in deutschland und ich
mitbekomme wie viele leute tatsächlich
zu hause privat feiern
da kann man die klubs auch wieder
aufsperren ja da ist was dran noch eine
wichtige frage du bist ja schon sehr
sehr lange im geschäft
hast du sicherlich auch ein überschuss
du kellners zwar aber ich vermute mal du
magst jetzt nicht am hungertuch gibt es
denn so tipps wie du jetzt in dieser
krise so dein geld anlegt
also mein geld anlegen da bin ich
momentan vorsichtig tatsächlich ja ich
habe rücklagen allerdings reicht es auch
nicht für die ewigkeit
auch sohn auch solo selbstständige hat
auch kosten jetzt natürlich nicht wie
eine große firma oder wie eine event
company allerdings ja da sind schon auch
dinge die weiterlaufenden verträgen
geschichten studio equipment
ich weiß nicht geld anlegen
vielleicht immobilien ich weiß es
nämlich keine handlung führt du bist ja
ja auch ein multiplikator wenn ich dir
jetzt 30 sekunden sendezeit gebe dass du
ein appell an die politik richten kannst
wie sieht dein appell aussah hat jetzt
30 sekunden
wow das ist jetzt ein bisschen sehr
spontan aber ja liebe regierende es wäre
schön wenn wir bald zur normalität
zurückkommen könnten die menschen wollen
kultur die menschen brauchen kultur die
menschen brauchen veranstaltungen und
events
es ist nicht geholfen den menschen so
viel angst zu machen ich glaube es wäre
weitaus sinnvoller konzepte zu finden
wie wir gemeinsam auch mit den
veranstaltern auch mit den künstlern
durch diese pandemie gehen oder dieses
corona virus eben gemeinsam besiegen
es wäre schön wenn die
veranstaltungsbranche nicht ganz in
vergessenheit gerät und eben nicht nach
hinten runter fällt und es ist eben
nicht nur die kulturschaffenden sind wie
opernhäuser oder schauspielhäuser
sondern es gibt eine ganz große branche
wir machen ganz viel umsatz in diesem
land und ich bitte vergesst uns nicht
bedingt denkt auch an die
musikschaffenden die djs die
eventbranche die veranstalter die
promoter die barkeeper all diese leute
sind seit über 170 tagen ohne arbeit und
die brauchen euch dringend lasst sie
nicht im stich
ja und dieser appell ist mit sicherheit
ankommt vielen dank tom novy wir drücken
die daumen dass es irgendwann wieder
bergauf geht